all right uh no grace period in dallas
as they try to get ready for the season
without ezekiel elliott he's still gone
there's no sign of any progress on a new
contract that would replace the final
two years of his rookie deal and
monday's development chris you saw this
coming i got to give you credit
reluctantly thank you it hurts me it
actually physically causes me pain to
say this but when we talked about jerry
jones and that flippant quip that zeke
zeku right comment when when his name
was brought up and he made it clear he
was joking everybody got a laugh out of
it everybody except ezekiel elliott
because his agent rocky arsenal told
chris mortensen of espn they didn't
think it's funny and of course he didn't
think it's funny as you said yesterday
you're talking about the guy's
livelihood you're talking about his
money he wants to be there right he
wants to be practicing he wants to be
getting ready to play the reason he's
not there is because the cowboys are
being obstinate about his contract so
yeah this was a misstep by jerry jones
probably has hardened the resolve of
ezekiel elliott yeah i would think so i
mean yeah it's disrespectful there's you
know and i know jerry jones didn't mean
to say it with malice but you know this
is a delicate situation and it is his
livelihood and i'll say this much too i
mean it's not going to go over great in
the locker room for a guy like jerry
jones either i mean not that they're
gonna like be like oh gosh our owner
doesn't have our back but they're gonna
be like wow
he clown he clowns on our best player i
mean he he kind of like throws some
shade at him and talking trash to one of
the best players on our football team
whoa you know and again i just i like
tony pollard i like what i see from him
but he's not ezekiel elliott and and i
don't know if they're really going to
know the worth of what they're missing
with ezekiel maybe until the real
regular season comes around and they're
playing against starting defensive
alignment and some game planning goes on
and all of a sudden the holes aren't the
size uh that mack trucks can go through
that we saw the other night against the
los angeles rams
yeah i've been doing the math here i'm
alive 54 years i've been talking for 52.
i don't know what the over under would
be on the number of
things i said without malice just trying
to have fun that got me in serious
trouble whether it was
spanked at age 8 or you know in the dog
house at age 50 uh but there's plenty of
times you think that that thing that's
coming out of your mouth is going to be
received with a smile right uh and and
sometimes it's not as i think we all
have learned the hard way over the years
so yeah just not a smart thing for jerry
jones to do and ezekiel elliott is upset
and and meanwhile
when are they going to get this worked
out yeah we have no sign of any progress
and we're two weeks and five days away
from the cowboys regular season opener
against the new york giant
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports